now thank you for joining us here at
noon I'm Heather Mills and we begin with
an update on a sex abuse case
surrounding a former actor and Las Vegas
local this morning Nathan chasenhorse
appeared in court for the first time and
we were there as the judge ordered that
he remained in custody without bail the
Dances with Wolves actor was taken into
custody on Tuesday when North Las Vegas
Police raided his home he's accused of
sex trafficking and sexually assaulting
teenage girls across several States for
the last two decades according to
sources chasing horse plan to tell his
victims to take suicide pills before
engaging in a shootout with police
police so far say at least six victims
have come forward we're gonna have much
more on this coming up in our later
editions of eight news now